they shot it through the cage almost as
if they were watching animals a lot of
times like in some way you understand
the the way it looked like
yeah very uh yeah like you said like
animals
tribal very tribal yeah just had like a
i felt like i was watching uh
you know like i remember at lsu they
used to have those videos on mike the
tiger all the time they'd shoot him just
kind of going through the cage you know
or doing something
do you think that you could fight an
animal everybody you think it's ever
going to get to that
what like a bear all right yeah i don't
know like if you think like i thought
like if you like a kangaroo with gloves
on like yeah if you could fight yeah
could you fight a couple
body shot that thing could you
really yeah i mean i don't i would
can they kick what's the rules the kicks
pissed me off dude i don't like when
people kick that much
i don't like dick kicks really people do
that no i mean not supposed to but it
happens
dude i'd rather fist fight a kangaroo
than go do a comedy show
dude i'm telling you i'm telling you
what's next is going to be a league that
travels around
and it's going to be men fighting
animals dude what about 40 foxes you
think you could fight 45
40. baker's dozen i guess yeah
yeah 40 foxes bro i'll bring some fox
meat
you know fight some kangaroos i'm just
sitting on your front porch wondering
how could i be so
far from my home
and my mind is somewhere else but when i
find it i'll patch up where it's been